let's get started domestically because i
thought this was a pretty this is this
is pretty big news
fox news reports dc prepares for
possible u.s freedom convoy officials
request national guard troops tow trucks
spotted near washington dc's national
mall
now i found this interesting
because when i was reading all of this
news all of these news outlets are
saying request for national guard
request for national guard and then fox
news seems to bury the lead outright
saying national guard troops will
reportedly deploy beginning tuesday and
remain in place until the end of march
the new york times i'm sorry fox news is
saying they have a source telling them
this
that the truckers are requesting a
permit for 1 000 3 000 people to gather
in the capital and the national guard
will reportedly be deploying tuesday and
remain in place until the end of march
so i don't know exactly what we're going
to see right now tow trucks are
apparently on scene in dc already and
they're saying they've been contracted
by the city for like 10 days or so and
i believe the the u.s freedom convoys
they're set to leave in a couple days
from barstow california it's barstow
right is that where we're getting a lot
of conflicting reports i was talking
with our field reporter about that today
and like we're comparing notes and it's
really hard to figure out exactly what's
going on right now but they're expecting
to be in dc what march 1st yes state of
the union
yeah that's the plan that's a bold time
to come in so they're already putting up
security perimeter fencing i think it's
going to look very very different to
what we saw in in canada
but i suppose
you know um the truckers are gonna be
prepared for that and i'm wondering
i'm wondering how things are gonna go i
mean the mandates out here in in the
states i mean they're going away it's
not the same as it is in canada and
canada it's absolutely brutal they're
beating people they're laughing about it
trampled some old old woman you know on
a mobility scooter and then the cops
were posting messages laughing about it
messages got leaked what do you guys
think's going to happen you think the us
is going to get rowdy yeah well i think
they're smart to get the permit first of
all right so you don't have a repeat you
don't put yourself in the same situation
what happened in canada and then uh
but
how
that that doesn't mean that everybody
involved in the convoy are going to act
the same way
yup so along the way i wouldn't be
surprised if they stopped somewhere and
clogged something ahead of getting to
the permit site right if you're looking
to make a statement and
so it'll be interesting to see how like
an fbi agent gets steps up on the back
of the truck and throws a brick and is
like hey the truckers are throwing
bricks i do not this is just red flags
uh red light flashing warning be careful
do not
they're ready for you the fascist
organization that is controlling the
united states and canada and all of the
western democracies this liberal
economic order is ready for you they're
planning for this they're already get
the national guard prepared they're
going to call people domestic terrorists
they're going to put people in solitary
be prepared ian you just cranked it all
the way up to 11. man
first you know the the international
cabal that's controlling the western yes
well uh i think it's fair to say that um
you know biden called trudeau they had a
conversation about the what's happening
with the convoy biden urged trudeau to
crack down with federal authority
trudeau then
started using these these insane
emergency powers to freeze bank accounts
so i would maybe turn it to 10 just go
down one notch i don't know if there's
some if it's a cabal like biden and
trudeau you know go and then hang out at
a secret meeting underground or anything
like that i certainly think these world
leaders have trade agreements have
economic ties
and whether whether or not you can say
there's one unified organization like as
if biden and trudeau literally work for
the world economic forum i don't know
about all that i know that they're
interested in supporting i know that
they're negotiating with i know they're
attend
they attend these similar events so you
know just one notch down but you know
i'm not completely in complete
disagreement yeah the bank of
international settlements loans money to
the bank of england and the uh federal
reserve of new york which is where i
don't know if canada gets their money
through england i don't know where they
where does canada print its money from
its central bank everyone's just
responding 20. yeah
it's just it's so true when you're up
against a machine gun nest we talked
about this yesterday you do not charge
straight at it that's what these people
have done they charged the position with
the canadian ones the defenders were
like unprepared they're like ah and then
they set up a machine gun nest to
protect the area now if you're going to
go at it you got to find new
methodologies man it is so dangerous to
repeat this action yeah and and the
other important thing too is with the
freedom convoy in canada they really
undermised underestimated it they they
had no idea they tried smearing it they
tried calling them violent none of it
works none of it sticks so then they say
okay we go we're going full fash they
just go full fascist they freeze bank
accounts they even get socialists like
vosh posting on twitter like whoa this
has gone too far they even get you know
more establishment types like steven
marsh was on the show saying like that's
martial law so they went over the top
i i'd be willing to bet
they've learned from those mistakes in
the united states very very different
from canada the police are going to be
way more brutal tear gas will be
deployed they're going to be embedded i
guarantee it in the trucker convoy the
moment they leave
following them every step of the way and
i think they're going to do everything
in their power to disrupt it but also
they're going to be spying on everything
the truckers say or do they need more
enemies the january 6th thing's getting
becoming old news and those people have
been off the radar
dude oh god when you have a huge
military you're constantly looking for a
place to use it because it's costing you
money if you're not
well look
we've all we all we all hear about
what's going on in ukraine and with with
russia and it's remarkable that that's
biden's priority i i know it's probably
a cliche at this point to bring it up
it's become a trope the southern border
is wide open just completely uh
obliterated people are pouring through
and the us government doesn't care and
so when i see that
you know my my view is it's very obvious
the biden administration has no
allegiance to this country
i just don't believe it i really really
don't sending troops to ukraine why to
help ukraine to help nato to help europe
what about us we don't have troops in
ukraine no we haven't been belarus or
where no we haven't been poland poland
so the 18th airborne in 82nd and the
82nd are there yeah now we do have from
what i've read we have troops
those who are doing training
which generally in the past that's
always been green berets when they're
put into uh that position that's who
generally do the training and they're
trying to help the ukrainian forces but
that's all the way close to the border
with ukraine so we we have no troops in
danger
they're in ukraine i just mean you know
why is it such a heavy priority for the
us to be involved in training in poland
and doing these things when we we're not
even taking care of ourselves well
it's really kind of a two-sided coin i
agree right something needs to be done
with the border but that is the plan the
plan is to keep it open right that is
the policy
and so obviously there isn't any other
way to stop it other than the states
along the border trying to build their
own walls trying to uh enforce
you know what is the actual law along
the border themselves so
i i get the analogy
but the danger of
uh what's going on in ukraine right now
is uh one it is immediate i'm not
talking about world war three this has
been a carefully orchestrated plan
on the part of putin and it's not going
to stop even if all he does is what he's
done now he's won
yep i mean he won with crimea no
absolutely yeah and then all he has to
do is take a break and redo it again
and i
you know i tweeted putin was afraid of
trump
and i i believe
i believe it
but i got response um i got a funny
response it was jermaine clement from
flight of flight of the concords
responded to me and he was he said
something like sure he was and it was a
picture of like putin sitting next to
trump or something and i'm like i don't
i don't know what that picture is
supposed to be i genuinely believe like
dude putin can walk up to trump and take
a picture with him and smile and laugh
putin wasn't afraid that donald trump
would physically harm him putin's kgb
training you know what does he do jiu
jitsu or whatever i don't think he's
afraid of trump on a physical man-to-man
level like he's going to walk up to oh
no it's trump he's afraid that trump is
insane
and that if he did something trump would
act irrationally and do something
irrational that would make it very
difficult for him to do exactly what
he's doing right but honestly whoever is
in office and i agree with what you're
saying to a certain degree
no one was going to stop them
okay i don't care who
was in office because we're not going to
put troops in ukraine because they are
not a member of nato yep so we have it's
both sides of defense have agreed right
there's already resolutions already
saying
boots on the ground no
support that's going to happen but
so
i do agree with what you're saying but
we're dealing with a different creature
in vladimir putin but under look so we
saw the escalation of this under obama
and then under trump it kind of just
fizzles it kind of just goes into stasis
biden gets in and all of a sudden it
ignites and ignites again no and true
but that is also part of the cycle and
this is i mean this is kind of what he
waits for right opportunity yeah
so when you have your opportunity you
strike so as we talk about more civil
unrest and civil disobedience here in
the united states listen
china and russia who are becoming closer
and closer together
we have the military capability to stop
either one not both
well i guess the fear is that uh if the
u.s becomes distracted
china moves in on taiwan or there have
been uh some experts who have argued
that china will adopt the russia
strategy on taiwan and use
pressure control manipulation propaganda
and just slowly eat away at it until
they can take taiwan i feel like the
americans a lot of americans are still
in the mindset of the b-52 the age of
the beef the war of the b-52 bomber like
it's not we're not the dominant force
anymore there's lasers that can blow up
everything from everywhere anyone thinks
that we got the biggest
balls on the planet uh are living in
1970 so
you actually saw trump one time was like
we have the best generals we can win any
and you see the generals like shut up
dude stop don't make us like don't put
us out there as like this this military
but do we really have the best generals
no no no we don't we don't and we don't
have the best military either all these
militaries are equally destructive at
this point well
at least the chinese russian and
american militaries if any one of them
wipe the planet clean they could do it
for the 11 aircraft carriers currently
floating around the world we own all of
them but one except how many nuclear
submarines are there that we don't see
to think that we're the best because we
it looks like we're the best it's really
difficult
i'm a little biased because i served oh
yeah
i think we are the best i not only and
the reason why i think we are the best
now is because we
when i was in
having a patch on your
left shoulder was very rare it came from
vietnam
now if you don't have one it's an oddity
we are battle hardened and tested
you're these are not just high school
kids just going in and and going through
just training but actually going through
the rigors of war and and i i think it's
a good point ian um we don't know you
know we we can we can only make
assumptions about the capabilities of
these other countries because they're
not they're going to tell us but the
same could be said for the united states
so for now if what we know is we don't
know what china secretly got because the
secret we don't know russia secretly
because it's a secret we don't know what
the u.s has because it's a secret as
well but the us on top of that has 11
aircraft carriers out there and doesn't
the u.s have like 20 or something like
that well
so the the largest air force in the
world is united states air force and
then the second largest is united states
navy yep
yeah air power that's right and and and
i'll just make one more point sorry uh
we can see with satellites when other
countries are building weapons
because we can see shipping lanes we can
see the movement of resources i can't
remember who was talking to us about
this they were saying like you know we
would know
if these other countries were building
warships or advanced technology because
of the massive amount of manpower and
resources to move all the stuff when it
came to the manhattan project we didn't
have satellite spot we didn't have spy
satellites or anything like that right
so when blasts were going off you know
censors were picking things up but the
russians they couldn't you know i'm
sorry this is uh during world war ii
like the you know axis powers were just
like what's happening
throughout the cold war with all the
nuclear testing we it was espionage like
physically go now we got satellites up
there just watching everybody they can
read your license plates so we can see
everything plus we have ai tracking all
the stuff and it'll be like we've
noticed a large deposit of iron being
shipped underground for some reason and
then the us is going to be like we know
something's being built there well and
the key is not simply to have the best
or the well-trained but you have to have
them in position to win
right this is why we don't want to i
mean i i thought larry sharp was a you
know that was awesome yesterday great
ideas but to get out of nato
that that would be a mistake
you have to have the force in position
or it's basically
not going to be able to react i think
about ground forces and now we're in the
age of intercontinental ballistic
missiles and rods from god tungsten rods
dropping from orbit like position we're
all in position now to get destroyed
but that hasn't changed it means like
it's been that way for a long time
not literally since when like not to
mention these or something but we're
we're targeting we're fighting warfare
with sanctions right now so biden's like
i'm going to sanction these rich guys
because they want to put pressure on
these ultra wealthy individuals who are
like hey man i like flying on planes and
eating you know steaks in new york city
don't sanction me and they're hoping
that influence will trickle down and
cause some change i think if we if the
u.s got embroiled it'd be like the power
grid gets blown up um and then they cut
off all their oil from from europe and
asia and no and then america's
done for like if the power goes i don't
know it feels like so vulnerable
everyone acts so tough and like we do
have great troops and we have we used to
have the best technology but now well
don't get me wrong i'm certainly not
advocating for any of it yeah but i'm
going to defend my brothers in arms also
look um
let me ask you guys
if uh the president came out and said we
need to build
wind farms solar power
so that we can be energy uh uh we can
have sufficient energy in the event of
war
do you think people would be like oh
that sounds good to me or do you think
they'd be like no no war don't do it
raytheon would be like that's a great
idea let's start building solar panels
but
is it isn't isn't that the appropriate
you know you've got the climate change
left right and you've got the energy
independent loving right couldn't they
just be alive we're going to be energy
independent so that no one no one can
screw with us hey the climate change
left wins on this one the right you know
we see the market energy independence we
went on this one where where it seems
like unity there no and there should be
because that's
the grid our electrical grid is one of
the most insecure part of our
infrastructure you know we we have a uh
investor of ours in fortitude ranch his
name is david tyson he's putting out a
documentary on this and it's really
excellent i i was able to get a sneak
peek
and it's
griddowndock.com you can actually go and
see the trailer and he's going to be
putting this out phenomenal job he
actually has a booth at the upcoming
cpac
this saturday and so he's looking to
launch that and it was so well done to
show
exactly how vulnerable we are
uh we have to
i just heard it too a couple news
outlets picked it up not not about his
documentary but about this fact because
of the possibility this thing gets out
of hand
are you know that's our weakest point
and when that happens
i'm sorry that's going to bring in uh
this the most serious crisis of our time
in the possible collapse and it'll be a
cyber attack and it will start with
cyber yeah we talked about before the
show we're talking about this and i
mentioned driving down the street and i
saw a big power plant just there and i
was like that's the most vulnerable
and then you would mention well that but
that's not even the cyber aspect of it
that's just the physical blunt trauma
you could inflict on the power grid
locally and think about sleeper cells
right
so if somebody's really looking to
destabilize us and things get out of
hand there
that that is going to be uh targeted
hasn't happened yet do you think that
this is
trump ordered the airstrike off
told him turn around come back home and
when asked why he said i asked how many
people were down there they said 500 and
i said it didn't make sense to kill that
many people in this strike so we called
it off
but one thing i noticed and it could be
totally unrelated was that
from the point where the airstrike was
deployed
in that moment
i believe it was some kind of oil
refinery in philadelphia exploded for
some reason
now i asked some of a bunch of my cyber
cybersecurity and um you know like
whitehead hacker buddies and they said
they didn't think in any way it was
related and i said is that because you
don't have evidence or because you think
it's impossible and they were like well
i have no reason to believe it sometimes
these accidents happen
but it's certainly possible
and so i i again there's no evidence to
suggest this to the case but is it
possible that trump ordered an air
strike and iran said blow up a a reactor
in blood refinery in philadelphia did
then they rushed to trump and they said
they're holding our facilities hostage
you need to can't call this off before
we get decimated from a cyber attack
one thing i can tell you is that
uh industrial control systems in the u.s
are extremely vulnerable to cyber
attacks because a lot of them were built
in the 70s they use this archaic and
ancient operating operating systems
they're being updated obviously and
security is a big issue
but man some of the people that i've
talked to who work in the security areas
of this stuff have just been like it's
like a few lines of basic code can blow
up this facility make me think of
stuxnet this is from a malicious
computer you've heard of this stuff
malicious computer worm first uncovered
in 2010 and thought to have been
developed since at least 2005. uh it
targets supervisory control and data
acquisition systems and is believed to
be responsible for causing substantial
damage to the nuclear program of iran
now if we did that to iran i'm not i
wouldn't be shocked if iran did that
back and i think it was uh it was the
u.s and israel working together on the
weapon yes and then uh what what it did
was it caused the nuclear centrifuges to
not stop so then they eventually
overheated and blew up
this is just one that we think that
we've uncovered stuxnet there's probably
i think i think it was because someone
found stuxnet infecting like home
computers or something i could be wrong
about that well and so the you know we
got the information from the israelis
the specifics and that's why we knew
exactly how the functioning inner
workings were with the pumps and the
different things that worked the
controlling mechanisms and so we went to
the heart i see so we figured out how it
worked then we wrote code to disrupt how
it worked it was it was specifically
written to do that one thing
it's crazy and and uh so my
understanding is that
people on their regular computers got
infected with stuxnet but it didn't
matter because it has zero effect on
your home computer it was just infecting
everything until it found those specific
you know controls those those machines
for five years until it was all covered
and then it blew them up and that was
like wow
okay so it's not the only one there's
been a bunch of uh
weapons that have been developed that
have been i think a couple i can't
remember the names and that's years ago
right right yeah it was like 10 years
ago so imagine imagine what's there now
what's out there i went to there's a
conventions there's two of them defcon
and black at the hacker conventions in
las vegas this is 10 years ago mind you
but i i saw these uh hackers
explain very easily how to blow up uh
pump stations they were like you name it
oil water any kind of chemical and they
did a demonstration where they showed
the industrial control system
they they showed it operate and then the
guy said i'm gonna i'm now gonna enter
our code and
activate you know press enter and then
all of a sudden they put a pressure
release valve but what they did was they
told the system to pull to force
pressure in in the same direction so the
pressure collides and built up in one
spot and causes a pipe to explode they
put a pressure release valve on it and
then it sprays across the room and they
catch it a pitcher and water sprays
everywhere they were like imagine if we
if we didn't have that release valve for
the purpose of the demonstration the
pipe would over pressurize and blow up
another thing they showed us was that
they said for nuclear reactor cooling
systems
there's the computer needs to know the
temperature of the water they said
only a few lines of code and we change
the temperature to say it's colder than
it is
overheats it explodes
that's or or melts down you know
disrupts the system if we're wargaming
this a worst case scenario or bad case
scenario there's conflict uh someone
wants to invade the country and then
they blow out the grid the electric grid
with the virus i don't know where to
take out the entire grid is there like a
backup plan and i don't even know if
you're the guy that knows the answers to
this steve but i'm asking you well you
know it's broken down into segments
right so there's there's four basic
hubs of where this work and how it would
affect it all are not
so intertwined that you could take it
all at once
um
but then you have the whole spectrum of
an emp right if if we ever get to that
day uh which would just completely fry
multiples because if you'd have to do it
at air burst you wouldn't want it to hit
the ground because that wouldn't have
the same effect but don't doing it as an
air burst then there would really be a
problem i think solar flares can cause
that too yeah to a degree we haven't
seen them you know the magnitude of them
would have to be much more than what we
normally see thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time